senator lindsey graham ron johnson said
mitch mcconnell doesn't speak for the
caucus i watched
your interview on fox news sunday with
chris wallace
and uh you pretty much said the same
thing lindsay
now maybe i'm wrong i did some research
today
i didn't find a whole lot of fighting
mitch mcconnell or john thune for that
matter
when it came to crossfire hurricane few
comments here and there
they were mostly missing in action for
that three-year battle
i didn't hear either one of them really
go after kamala harris
chuck schumer joe biden nancy pelosi of
maxine waters either
not particularly happy with the double
standard myself
well yeah number one senator mcconnell's
speech saturday i don't think his widely
shared view of president trump
uh by most republicans but remember you
said you're a conservative
a democratic majority in the house in
the senate with a democratic president
is a nightmare for the pro-life movement
for the second amendment
we're going back to open borders and
asylum seekers
and gonna have a very weak foreign
policy
president trump's statement today in
response to what mcconnell said saturday
is very predictable i remind everybody
ronald reagan
11th commandment was don't speak ill of
fellow republicans
why do people like president trump so
much in the republican party
he was a damn good president uh he
rebuilt the military
he brought order to chaos at the border
he cut our taxes
he put isis destroyed the caliphate put
iran in a box
and put three great supreme court
justices on the supreme court
and hundreds of conservative judges
throughout the federal judiciary
but i want you to know this mitch
mcconsul
mcconnell was indispensable to donald
trump's success
mitch mcconnell got the tax cut through
a massive tax cut
with a two vote republican majority
mitch mcconnell
as much to credit for amy comey barrett
as any single person
mitch mcconnell working with donald
trump did a hell of a job
they're now at each other's throat i'm
more worried about 2022
than i've ever been i don't want to eat
our own president trump is the most
consequential
republican in the party if mitch
mcconnell doesn't understand that he's
missing a lot
but my beef is not with mitch mcconnell
because he has the same policy views
i do my beef is that we need to knock
this off kevin mccarthy is the leader of
the house republicans
he's taken different approach to
president trump i would advise senator
mcconnell to do that as to president
trump
in that poll you own the republican
party my friend
but 55 of the people wanted you
impeached and removed
you are the hope of the future of
conservatism president trump
but we got to make some changes to get
back the white house in 2024
and have a republican majority and the
senate in the house in 2022
i believe the democrats are doing all
they can to help us
we just need to help ourselves look the
the establishment
wing of the republican party they you
can look at it
say through the the lincoln project for
example uh
they don't seem again putting stylistic
issues aside
the agenda of donald trump was a con a
conservative's dream
and he kept the promise fought every day
and got it accomplished
and it's not easy to get that much
accomplished in four years anybody would
recognize that
um what bothers me though is if the
people that are
the people that are throwing the first
punch here are the establishment
republicans
and if they have their way donald trump
supporters you know
be gone and they think that they'll take
control now
i think donald trump has i think he's
been able to wake a lot of people up to
how it needs to get done in washington
because
the old style is gone and and that
i'd rather be battling socialist
socialism
joe's radical new green deal and
everything free
and destroying the economy and weak
weakness with israel and around the
world
i'd rather fight them and align where we
can align and if we agree 80 percent of
the time that's fine
sean i hope people listen to what you
just said i'm going to go to the border
thursday and friday and i'm going to
report to you next week on your show if
you'll have me
the disaster in the making because
biden's changing all of trump's policies
about remaining in mexico
going back to the old asylum law we're
going to have a run on the border like
you've never seen
again mitch mcconnell was indispensable
to president trump in getting the judges
on the court
getting a major tax cut through in a
very narrow senate
majority but what i would say to senator
mcconnell i know trump can be a handful
but he is the most dominant figure in
the republican party
we don't have a snowball's chance in
hell of taking back the majority without
donald trump
if you don't get that you're just not
looking he was a hell of a president
all the on all the things that
conservatives really
believe in it was a consequential
presidency i'm sorry what happened on
january the 6th he'll get his fair share
of blame
but to my republican colleagues in the
senate
let's try to work together realize that
without president trump
we're never going to get back in the
majority and to president trump
you're going to have to make some
changes for you to reach your potential
now at the end of the day we're going to
hang we're going to hang separately
or we're going to hang together as
republicans i want to see him use the
same type of indignation
outrage against the language of schumer
carmilla
waters and guess what we haven't seen it
and if he's not going to do that he's
not in a position to lead anybody
all right lindsey graham thank you
coming